what's going on we just had uh um death
man
in we had frank giles in here
and i tell you you know it's it's
interesting when you meet a man
that's that close to the dead
and you're right there you're with him
you know it's interesting when you when
you meet a man who who
who who's carried a you know that that's
that 15 inch baby
and tucked him into a car seat next to
him and driven him over there to the
death grounds
it's interesting to be that close to
that man and just kind of just hear his
feelings
hell i asked him straight up i said let
me put my hand on your chest
you know let me feel the drum of the of
of of
of death because when he walks in the
room baby
that's it you were to go order for the
lord son you it's time to box you up
and so yeah i guess i start thinking
about that around this time of year
what's it gonna be like
when they close when they roll it up one
more time
you know i tried to fake my death when i
was about 20.
i'll be honest
and my friend paul called a couple
people and said hey you know theo's dead
and
and the [ __ ] the crazy [ __ ] was none of
them even told anybody
so we planted a couple seeds and that
[ __ ] didn't even grow bro
and then we forgot about it you know we
was doing weed we was doing cocaine
daddy you know
i mean i was anyway i don't know if he
was but
you know my favorite type of weed was uh
cocaine you'd see me snorting a bowl of
weed you know
get that little that thanksgiving for
your snout daddy i'm talking about
cocaine
dude i remember i had some i had some
good cocaine one time over there in
tucson arizona
hell i put two grams in my car was out
of gas and that [ __ ] ran for a half an
hour
the headlights wouldn't work but hey you
can't have it all
daddy you can't have it all
and that's god man but yeah we had the
death man in here we had him right here
and it's crazy i mean if say fast
forward 40 years from now 80 years from
now when i die
or when i you know go on
i should have told i should have put my
order in i should have said hey frank i
want this you know i want this and this
i want you know i want the i want the
strawberries and whipped cream on
one under each arm when i'm in that
basket daddy
and i want that wicker casket so you
could still still smell me
so the ladies could still get a off of
my bro loan you feel me
but i don't know it's tricky how do you
want to go
cremated is too much i don't want to be
you know i worked one day as a damn uh
chef's apprentice over at um
uh over at road house cafe or whatever
that [ __ ] hole was
um link lock i don't know what it was
dude they were supposed to be selling
charred grilled steaks but
the fda showed up and popped them and
got them they were selling um
they were selling illegal uh meat
you know they had to hit a raf in there
they had hit a pony or something you
know
some of the [ __ ] they were selling was
illegal meat
and that's the second time in my life
i've been popped at a joint where
they're selling illegal
you know i was out in tucson arizona and
they had this little chef fella
named little scotty and they popped him
and he wore a big ass hat
too heavy for his neck and you would see
him kind of like this a little bit
and that the hat was so damn heavy it
would close his eyelids man but
you know when you're a chef they don't
give you like a medallion
you know some things that give you a
medallion if you do well
but a chef they give you a big hat looks
kind of like an
like an atomic bomb explosion shape
and he was so damn proud and i think his
daddy thought he was bigger and his
daddy hadn't seen him in a while
and his daddy got him too heavy of a hat
for his little neck
and so he had that big bastard on there
and he could barely keep his eyes open
with that heavy [ __ ] on there
but they uh yeah they got but they were
selling illegal seafood and i remember
the fda showed up
and popped everybody dude you know
some dude asking me if i know about
shrimp [ __ ] i don't know about [ __ ] i'm
a bus
boy okay and they need bread on eight
right now
so don't try to tangle me up all in this
little mermaid [ __ ]
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one